Fall is almost here.
That means cold
and flu season is right behind it.
And now,
of course,
COVID 19,
just like we should get a flu shot
every year, experts say.
We'll likely have to get an updated
COVID 19 shot every year.
The FDA and CDC have approved
the latest COVID
19 vaccines
from Moderna and Pfizer BioNTech
as if that is not enough
doctors are warning that
another respiratory virus,
RSV, could also be a problem this fall.
Oh, goodness.
Well, joining me now to talk about
who needs which vaccine and when is Dr.
Sargent
Matthew is a primary care
physician and public health specialist.
The public health
emergency is over,
but we know COVID isn't going away.
So how important is it
for people
to at least get this updated vaccine?
Well, you know,
let me just break it down.
I know
people are tired of hearing
about COVID and booster shots.
The good news is
CDC has recommended broadly
that everybody six months
and older
should get this new COVID booster.
And just like we get an updated
cell phone,
you want to make sure that your vaccine
is updated
to cover the variants
that are currently in the environment.
You see, most Americans I'm right.
Were probably vaccinated a year ago.
I've got tons of patients who forgot
when the last booster shot was.
So you get the waning immunity.
And even though you have infections
in the community,
the protection from an infection
also wanes.
So we are actually in a late
summer, early fall surge as we speak.
So what's your reaction to what
we're hearing from the Florida
surgeon general
who says not only
I mean, he's
not saying that people don't need it.
He's saying that people under 65
and those without a serious health risk
should not
get the updated COVID 19 vaccine.
To be honest, Victor,
there's
definitely a difference in opinion
among scientists in terms of
should this be broadly
administered to patients
six months and older,
or should we just
protect the most vulnerable, the elderly
and the young kids
and people
that may have asthma,
diabetes, hypertension.
And I think ultimately, here's
here's the deal.
We did not do a good job with the rollout
the last time with vaccines.
I think this time
CDC should just be very clear
and make it simple for everybody.
Even if you are a young
20 year old athlete or an 80 year
old person,
the risk of COVID is still there.
And with multiple infections,
Victor, I worry more about long COVID.
So let's talk about flu and COVID.
Right?
So in terms of the vaccines,
can you get them at the same time?
Do post it out?
And also, I wanted to ask you,
you know,
I know a couple of people who got the flu
and COVID basically at the same time.
So in terms of treatment,
I mean, does
one should one
take priority over the other
or can you get treated for
both at the same time?
Well, you know, to answer your first
or your last question first. Yeah.
Ultimately,
anybody can get COVID vaccine
and flu shot at the same time.
You can get at the same time.
I would recommend that
if you have the time,
you're not traveling.
You don't have to protect
an elderly member in the family.
Maybe space it out,
get the flu shot once a week,
and then the following week at COVID 19,
very rarely
can you get side effects
to both vaccines.
So I recommend spacing it out
in terms of treatment.
It's always a nightmare for primary care
physicians like me.
I dread the winter time
because when patients come in
with a cold, a cough,
you don't really know.
Is it COVID 19 Is it the flu?
Or could it be RSV?
Are these new?
Are the tests for COVID?
Picking up the new variants
and strains
because we have an executive producer
whose homes they took six tests.
Yeah, it's not COVID.
We now know it's the flu.
But when he said
he took six tests,
my question was,
does the test know the new variant?
Yeah.
I mean, you are hitting it
right on the nail, Victor.
I actually tweeted the other day
that a lot of patients
are being misdiagnosed with bronchitis.
So by the time they get to me,
they've tested twice
and they're like, Dr.
Matthew, I don't have COVID,
but I am sick.
And that's
because a lot of these
rapid tests are not picking up
the old Macron strains
and also depends on
how deep you go up in the nose.
I hate to call it a brain biopsy,
but that's it is a
I must say it is a brain emergency.
I mean, you are going to be cringing.
It is painful for a quick second.
So people are not going up
that,
you know, deep into the nasal cavity.
So, yes,
there are a lot of false negatives
with a rapid test.
I mean, so RSV, flu and COVID.
Great.
Three things to worry about.
Is there any distinction
in terms of symptoms at all?
You know, with the Omicron infection
right now,
it tends to be more like cold
like symptoms.
You know,
it's definitely become more of
nasal congestion.
Fatigue, headache.
Well, guess what?
That also could be with the flu.
One thing to distinguish
that is a sudden onset,
you're going to feel like a ton of bricks
hit you at one time.
So body aches and fevers.
So that will distinguish the flu.
But when it comes to RSV and COVID 19,
it can be tough,
can be tough to make,
to really distinguish
between between both of them.
But I tell patients, listen,
if you really want to know
if you have COVID,
wait a couple of days
and get the PCR test.
I know
PCR test is not available to everybody.
But it is way more accurate
than the rapid home tests.
Correct.
My pronunciation
of this, but phenylephrine
this decongestant in this
over-the-counter medicines,
the FDA determined
that they just don't work
right
after being on the market
as safe and effective for 50 years.
They're in DayQuil and Sudafed
and NyQuil NyQuil.
And so aside from how could that happen?
Looking forward, what do people use now?
What works there?
So many other over-the-counter options
like Flonase, right?
Of course,
you don't need a doctor's prescription
for that.
And Sudafed,
which is the stronger version of Fennel
and has always been available
it's just that it's
now behind the counter.
You actually have to go up
to the pharmacist
and show your license
because Sudafed was actually used
as a street drug to make meth.
So fennel,
electronic actually
isn't a lot of products
like you mentioned.
And get this, Victor, last year,
over 200 million products of fennel F1
were sold
ripping $1.74 billion in profit.
That is how common fennel did
nothing different and did nothing.
Wow. My gosh. All right.
So as you good to have you in.
Thanks so much for coming. Thank you.